yeah i mean like
even
like deep during the pandemic when i
heard about the 5g things because well i
i i'm so bad yeah okay yeah i i remember
back back when it started we were just
like haha look at look at all the silly
americans yeah yeah
british people in the uk legitimately
think that crazy people only exist yeah
yeah no they don't they don't believe
that crazy people exist in the uk yeah
i'm sorry crazy people exist everywhere
yeah i've done all these news articles
about people like burning 5g towers in
the uk came out and the rest of the
world were like yo get your mans get
your man so i'll just like
say my man's man
i'm part of japan now
uh japanese citizen uh
it's really bad it's like it was it was
all the videos online of 5g towers being
torn down or like set on fire every time
i was watching i was like oh where was
this florida or something and then you
hear a really big thick british accent
it's my man
[ __ ]
oh god
it's pretty bad yeah because like i yeah
i don't know if we were just blind to
this when we were living there but i've
it oh it's just been exacerbated oh it's
been exacerbated yeah it's like five
years it's gone live
it's skyrocketed and yeah it's really
pretty tragic and i feel like especially
during like these past few years we've
seen like the [ __ ] stupidest parts of
humanity just like on or like on [ __ ]
front and center yep yeah i think right
they don't know they don't think they're
being stupid
it's unfortunate that you know our
country was like part of that stupidity
we thought every country thinks they're
mean to it but we thought we soon find
out that we are we are not just as
capable of being stupid
any country with internet it's going to
happen too
you know every single every country that
that has the internet it's unfortunate
do you know what i realized uh you know
like every cheesy hero movie or every
like cheesy heroic moment where the hero
asks the entire world to come together
and how to cooperate like do you
remember that scene in dragon ball z
where goku asks everyone to [ __ ] give
me your energy give him energy for the
spirit bomb i realized that's entirely
[ __ ] [ __ ] like imagine if that
tried to even imagine if that like
happened in real life you know like the
[ __ ] americans would argue whether
they have the right to not put their
hands up right japan would take six
months to approve any of their citizens
putting their hands up the uk would
start would start burning 5g towers and
australia would probably go back
lockdown on the ground
they put into
like no one would [ __ ] put their
hands up
oh my god i would like i would like to
see that i would like to see that goku
scene postcode let's let's see how that
turns
out think it would go on for twice as
many episodes right it's like
it's just like it's just like the bad
guy's just like i'm waiting goku has to
go on a pr trip around the world kissing
babies
goku has to go and joe broken
[Laughter]
so what you're saying is goku is that
everybody has to put their hands up yeah
really really
yeah people be like i don't know it's a
right-wing thing to say i don't know
about this margin boo character you say
he's the greatest threat in the universe
how come i haven't heard of him yeah
sounds like a hoax to me
he's probably turning the frog's game
have you got any proof that he exists
that he's not some liberal some
something made up by the liberals
it's liberal propaganda i tell you oh my
god someone someone needs to make a
political satire of dragon ball z that'd
be the funniest thing in the world
new grounds
you need to come out of the dark ages
let's make that
it sucks just being like
i don't give a [ __ ] about any of this
yeah it sucks being like yo you're all
crazy yeah what are you guys doing yeah
just just be normal
it's so hard it's so hard to be normal
because that in itself is a [ __ ] take
that's like what do you mean you don't
have strong opinions on this weird [ __ ]
that i read
man i'm online trying to chill man i
just think that like why don't you be
nice to people i don't know it must be
nice to have the privilege to just chill
yeah i think you know at the end of the
day i you know i it's one of those
things where i it's unfortunate because
i don't think inherently people i think
there are small amount people that
genuinely are like extremely
hateful in a sense yeah i don't think
you know it's why i i hate demonizing
any side too much i don't like just
saying one side is right because i think
at the end of the day even though as
long as they're not posting harmful
stuff which unfortunately they are yeah
they are posting harmful misinformation
it sucks because i don't think that
anyone is
inherently like evil or trying to spread
hate i think they genuinely just believe
that what they are spreading is gonna
save people's lives or help people which
sucks because then then when someone
believes that firmly about it it is like
impossible to change their mind i i
think it's just it's been exacerbated by
the internet i mean it's it's like being
in social media it's so easy just to
fall in an echo chamber right where
where because you think a certain way
and there's nothing you get exposed to
that challenges you or challenges the
way you're thinking right because
you know in the old days you hear
something you hear something that you
disagree with and maybe you have a maybe
you have a debate or you know maybe you
you talk to someone about it but in here
you can just simply mute them or you can
just simply not follow people who have
that opinion i think i think that's the
problem i have with it it's like i don't
really mind people giving like extreme
opinions about things yeah on the
internet right and you know believing in
something that they firmly believe in
right the problem i have is that no
one's having a [ __ ] open conversation
about it right and no one is no one is
ready to be like
say say the opposite opinion to me i'm
listening and i will and i will try and
understand it the best i can so that's
just like blah blah blah can't hear you
i'm right [ __ ] you mute you know
you know it's it's uh the internet's
very powerful because i think growing up
anything you read it's in a it's in
books it must be true yeah you've been
told that stuff you read or stuff that
you experience or stuff that you're told
is always true yeah so and even then
it's not sometimes right like i remember
when i was like 12 and i first came
across like the moon landing conspiracy
yeah
and like for like a week i probably
thought it was true yeah because i i
read it and i thought well that makes
sense they this person explained it well
enough to me yeah and then you know but
i was 12 i was 13 or whatever you know
like you're a [ __ ] idiot you can't
think about stuff yeah you can't yeah
you can't be like oh maybe they cherry
picked you like they presented
information this all seems like it makes
sense in my world and that i understand
so it's it's uh it's tough and some
people i feel like almost kind of have
that mindset going forward and never
really like tend to think oh maybe i
should look at other stuff yeah what was
that quote like history is never written
by the losers or something like that
it's it's important because it's like it
takes energy and time to look at the
other side and a lot of people don't
have the energy in time to look at the
other side nowadays and it's just you
have to like train yourself to like kind
of like no you have you have to go
against
your you know your own gut feeling and
you're just like okay i have to
literally go out of my comfort zone and
see what the other side is saying which
is why like on my social media i try
even if i don't even if there's someone
out there who i don't agree with i still
like sometimes follow them or i still
like sometimes want them to appear in my
feed just so just so like i know what
the other side is you grounded yeah i i
do hate this idea that you can't follow
anyone who has like controversial takes
or anything on twitter i'm like
so what it's like you know you're not
promoting them if you're following them
it's like all right well just let them
[ __ ] follow them like yeah what harm
does it do why would you want an echo
chamber i don't understand this thought
process of only experiencing your your
thought process and people who think
similarly to you yeah to me yeah i think
if you're just surrounded by nothing but
yes man that equally turns you into a
bad person because
like [ __ ] war crimes or genocide
obviously maybe it's a little different
but if someone just said something
that's a bit yikes on twitter it's like
i mean if someone just gave an opinion
right yes it's tough right i mean
pewdiepie got cancelled for that or
cancelled right remember like he's
following he's ben shapiro or something
yeah yeah he's [ __ ] he's right-wing
bro or jordan piece or whatever like
that kind of [ __ ]
and i think that's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's that's like the next level of
just like oh you it's not even you agree
with this person it's you are
you have a platform where you listen to
this person by by therefore you are
supporting them yeah it's like that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe i just want to
know what the other side is saying
because i think it's interesting to see
to have a different perspective even if
i don't necessarily [ __ ] agree with
it yeah and like i think i think
a big reason why i just like don't have
the energy for like a lot of politics
nowadays or like this this spectrum of
mentality is that everyone has something
to say but everyone knows what they
stand against but no one knows what they
stand for that's that's that's how i
feel where you can like a lot there's so
many people who say you can say this is
bad i disagree with this i disagree with
this person i disagree with that person
but they've never told me what they
stand for or what you know what what
their fight you know what what their
opinions are standing for and i'm just
like well you know what you you can just
you can discredit someone but you can't
come up with an argument for your own
values or your own views and i i think i
think that's why i [ __ ]
that that's why like i don't have the
energy for this anymore that's why that
that's why i've started to just you know
i've i just listen to people i like
listening to people and i feel like even
listening to the other side of the
argument really broadens your horizons
even if it's something you don't agree
with or even if you think the other side
is [ __ ] stupid which you know you
know it can happen certainly it does
keep you grounded true and it does help
form your vote would you form your world
view as well yeah absolutely